dire que je suis fou de toi ne rend pas
justice à la profondeur de mes
sentiments je t'aime je t'adore arrive
je ferai tout pour toi je serai l'homme
le plus heureux de la planète si tu
acceptes d'être ma faim ça veut dire
quoi que je peux savoir faut l'accord de
son père c'est ça non il faut celui de
son frère aîné semble à tout ce qui
compte et vous arrêtez de vous battre
vous êtes plan des plans pas violent
c'est le clown six heures avec ma soeur
se garer pas plus grand qu'un jeu
trompait légiste entrée dans la famille
proche exactement ce qu'ils veulent tu
veux le marteau affronte un score très
serré alors ça suffit
arrêtez vos conneries je t'interdis de
[ __ ] ma vie en l'air
jolène on tient monsieur jeu pur comme
une bande s j'ai juste répondu présent
dans un contexte hostile mais moi je dis
que c'est tacle conteste sa garde si non
pourquoi
regarde encore même si j'ai besoin de
points d'accord pour demander angela en
mariage montre moi tes digne d'elle et
je dois faire quoi tous à patrouiller
une journée rien qu'avec moi ouais c'est
ta mise à l'épreuve
il a déjà tenu une arme avant la
spécialité sept fusils attention il
échangeait avec 2,12 et l'estomac dans
le cul ah ouais t'es prêt pour la rue a
du bol d'or est tombé sur moi des règles
à suivre tu touches jamais suspect sauf
si tu dois l'embarqué bon jouer au tueur
parce que vous êtes en pente le vrai dur
ici c'est moi alors tu fait dans son
froc briser la nuque
comment ça s'est passé pour toi là-bas
ça serait beaucoup mieux passé
surveillants plain white a plombé da
ponte tâche l'ouest et plombe et
accrochages
[Musique]
tandis que je rêve c'est pas mal et toi
tu sors ton feu devant une beauté aussi
sexy et samba bébé j'avais pas vu la
petite différence
merci aussi à 'plus bas' il prend tout
un truc que j'arrive tout de suite